it had been another long and ugly night
of violence on the streets of kenosha
when at midnight after crowds had
largely been dispersed
a man armed with a weapon was chased in
the street and knocked to the ground
several shots were then fired before he
was seen to get
up and surrender himself to law
enforcement officers
arriving on the scene with his arms in
the air
this has been the third night of
violence here following the shooting of
jacob blink
a crowd several hundred strong gathered
outside the grounds of this city's
courthouse
targeting law enforcement officers
inside i think with our current
political situation
america seems stuck but within
communities and within the local places
it seems like change is actually
happening
my son should be able to leave out of my
home and i don't have to worry
or if he's mom can i use the car and i
have to tell him no because
i'm afraid a cop is going to shoot him
this cycle of protest has at its heart
human despair
embodied here by the family of jacob
blake who had earlier spoken to the
media
of their son and his shooting please
let's begin to pray for healing for our
nation
we are the united states have we been
united
do you understand what's going to happen
when we fall because a house that is
against each other cannot stand
the national guard had been increased in
number on night three
it didn't stop president trump tweeting
the governor saying he should call it
in it is ready he posted willing and
more than able
and problem fast for a president
watching events from a distance
there were thoughts from a man rather
closer jacob blake's father
mr blake would you have a message for
donald trump
if i told you what i thought about
donald trump and turn your phone off
you got him in some ways responsible for
what happened him and responsible for
raising hatred
feeding it feeding the flames of hatred
this was the incident in which jacob
blake was shot
his family say he's paralyzed from the
waist down
new video from a different angle appears
to show struggle with officers
prior to the shooting
two officers have been placed on
administrative leave pending
investigations
jacob blake's family want them arrested
this is all taking place in the middle
of downtown kenosha
in a civic center park were just hours
earlier
the mother of jacob blake called for an
end to this kind of protest
saying it's not what her son would have
wanted
she said she wanted a healing for the
country
it needs to end the hurting first
james matthews sky news wisconsin